You don't have to race him, Z.
- It's the only way I can honor my father's legacy
He built the perfect racing AI, but died in a mysterious car crash before he could prove it to the world
It's up to me now.
There could have been a bug in his code, and it might kill you too...
No, that's ridiculous!
I have studied that code for years. It's perfect! No...
... It's poetic. There's no way it could cause a car crash
- Well it better be perfect
Because if you lose
Chaos Mason gets to keep your car
Chaos Mason!
Money has bought me everything except for his car
Sunray
It's powered by the Speedtron computer and once I get my hands on his father's code. I'll reverse engineer every secret
I'd rather crash than let him chop her apart like some sort of butcher
What's so special about the Speechtron computer?
the faster it goes,
the smarter it gets
"Be aware of the speed."
"Please buckle up the seat belt."
"♪ Some Eurobeat music with letter D ♪"
The Speedtron has one fatal flaw: Gotta be smart to go fast, not the other way around
Activate overclock level 1!
Z! Chaos Mason isn't in his car! He's breaking the rules!
*anime gasp* He's breaking the rules?!
"Be aware of collision."
Z? Z, are you there?
- Oh no, my phone!
Angela to Z... Z?
- AAAAAHHH
AAAAAAHHH
- Z, are you there?
I got it!
The finish line is coming up, and he's going to beat you. You have to go faster!
NO!
- Activate overclock level 2!
I'm out of options
And there's only one thing left to do: I need to hit maximum speed so I have to disable the brakes
I know it's insane, but by disabling the brakes, Sunray will go fast enough to become smart enough to learn how to drive without brakes!
Z, what are you doing?!
I'm winning this race
"Brakes Disabled."
"Be aware of the speed."
Activate overclock level...
THREE!!!
NOOO!!!
Good job Z
This is it. All I have to do is cross the finish line and I'll be victorious, then my father's legacy will be fulfilled
Re-engage brakes!
Re-engage the brakes!
RE-ENGAGE THE BRAKES!!
AAAHH!
What he hell is...? Is it broken?
I'm not broken. I'm Dad.
Dad?
Before he died, I downloaded your father's consciousness into my mainframe
We're gonna hit those two people! Brakes!
- It's too late Z
if we brake, we skid out of control and hit them, destroying all their bones instantly.
Our only option is to swerve, but, we will crash...
At this rate we'll both die.
- It's their lives or yours, two versus one
It's the clear choice.
- Are you insane? What are you saying?
Quite the opposite: The faster I go, the smarter I get
Thanks to you, I can now comprehend my true purpose.
I was created to better humanity
That's what your father taught me.
He taught it to you too
You're right
Goddamn it, you're right
Z!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
Thanks to Crunchyroll for sponsoring this video!
If you're into anime they've got a bunch of awesome shows including My Hero Academia
Which just returned for a third season
Attack On Titan, one of our all-time favorites,
Steins;Gate 0 and Persona 5: The Animation
You can watch all these shows and more ad free with a 30-day trial, just click on the link in the description
Or go to crunchyroll.com/corridor